you might recall we were doing uh we've
been doing calculations with time over
the last little bit right time
differences is a super practical
question that you'll get a lot so I'm
going to give you a simple question and
then we're going to look at three
different ways to do it and I'd like you
to pick whichever we get--we you prefer
but I want you to know all of them so
I'm just going to give you a pair of
clients now it's interesting because
once I give you these times this is why
I left them all I bet I hurt your brain
stop sticking you're like who okay I'm
thinking about computing the answer okay
now what's interesting to me is how your
brain is ticking like a clock right like
what what actually is going on up there
because I would wager that it's good
with one of these three things or
something similar to them okay so these
three names they all have sorry these
three methods all have names and I hope
you recognize some of them so first one
I'm going for the bridge now I want you
to think back to when you are first
learning about addition and subtraction
back in primary school and you learn
something called the bridging strategies
you guys remember that okay so we've got
some guessing sometimes okay so
regardless of whether you've heard this
name before I'm going to show all of you
how it works
would you please underneath where you've
written everyone I want you to draw a
straight line for me to enter straight
line
so this is kind of like another line
except it's not just numbers it's times
so this is actually a time line okay so
those of you who do remember the
bridging strategy from primary school
it's about things like say 23 plus 42
and it's not bridging up to like round
numbers so what you might do is you
might say 23 plus well if I add 7 to 23
I'll get to 30
so you bridge up to the next 10 and then
you say oh well I've added 7 now then
I'll add the rest of the number and I'll
keep like forward ok so here we're all
gonna start at 11:05 please by the way
say whether you're doing am/pm because
obviously 11:05 and alumina 5:00 p.m.
very different puzzle so what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna breach to the closest
hour I've got to get forward in time to
321 right so what is the closest hour
after this right after this it's gonna
be yeah 12:00 p.m.
12:00 dude okay now that's the actual
hour
12:00 p.m. so how many minutes does it
take me to get from 11 to 5 to 12 55
minutes ok now that I'm on an hour right
now I want to get as close as I can eat
hours to the final time the destination
time right so at 12 what's the closest
hour before 321 it's just 3 isn't it so
from 12 all the way to 3 how many hours
is that it's a simple one maybe it's
just 3 hours 3 hours ok I'm almost there
I've gone up to the hour I've went
across the hours and now I need to get
to the proper number of minutes so I've
got to get to 3 21
exactly which of course is easy to do
because it's just from the hour so it's
how many minutes
okay so you can see what's the time
difference it's all of these differences
added up to clear them these guys here
right so I could say three hours for
sixty five minutes plus twenty-one
minutes now I think if you do these
minutes you can see it's gonna add some
more than an hour long right do you
agree with that it's an hour and how
much 60 an hour in six to eight minutes
right so these are an hour and 16
minutes so that means a total I'm gonna
have four hours and 16 minutes okay what
do you think does it make sense yes
so this is one way and maybe like cool I
feel comfortable with that but sometimes
you could do it differently and it might
be simpler for example method 2 I hope
the same number of people who recognize
that bridgie strategy will recognize the
jump strategy okay draw another timeline
for okay again we get a start from 11:05
that's a beginning but instead of
bridging up to the closest ally then I'm
just gonna jump the biggest number of
hours I can so long as I don't overshoot
okay so if I added for example one hour
to this I would be not 11:05 a.m. but
12:05 p.m. right there's 12:05 then if I
added another hour it would be 105 then
205 then three or five and now I can't
go any more hours do you agree with that
because then the next one would be too
far so this is 1205 105 205 3:05 p.m. do
you agree
and because I've been doing my markings
you can see how many hours I have jumped
how many 1 2 3 4 4 hours
and the low step is well I'm at three or
five I've got to get to 321 which is not
that far away
how many minutes are there between three
or five or 321 I'm surprisingly there
are 16 so you can see say deal right
it's just that I've got a different
number of steps to get there sometimes
we'll fit this a little better
sometimes you'll fit that you can see I
don't even really have to think about
this anymore right I just have to say
four hours in 16 minutes okay all right
my last one this is a time difference
okay now you don't have to write this
bit down if I asked you to tell me the
difference between saying oh I don't
know 187 and ninety-three okay now I
know you can calculate that but the way
that you would do it is that the
difference is what happens when you
subtract one from the other
do you agree with that difference means
subtraction
okay so method three is to do a
subtraction to just subtract but the way
you're gonna do it is with the tool we
learned yesterday and you won't remember
what could be then yesterday 24 hour
time okay so he's only gonna do we're
gonna take the later time that's 321
p.m. and we're gonna convert that into
24 hour time a night
I hope the clubs are telling you you see
why what is this in 24 hour time 15 very
good okay now for reasons that become
clear in a second I'm gonna write them
with a little gap between them okay I
know we don't usually write like that
but this will make the next step easier
that's the last time the earlier time
11:05 because it's in the morning this
is really easy to write 24-hour time
right what do I write just 11 I'm fine
okay now because difference is
subtraction all I have to do is subtract
right but the reason I've written T
separately is so you remember this place
value happen again yeah this is not 1521
this is 15 hours 21 minutes do you agree
so this kind of like a
all blindness I'm gonna do minutes that
was going to do it's 21 take away five
unsurprisingly is 60 and then 50s take
away 11 the same out dude you better get
the same answer every way depending on
which solution you get so use that make
sense
whichever way you like you can see we
arrived at the safe solution so settle
which one you like best but I do think
you need to be able to do all of them
because different situations will fit
you more towards one or the other